[Music]
this is a market in russian occupied her
son southern ukraine
the city fell to russian forces in early
march this footage acquired by al
jazeera shows how much life has changed
since much of it was filmed secretly
russia's invasion has ended access to
ukrainian products and those produced in
russia are expensive and take time to
arrive
much of the vodka and beer is homemade
russia changed the currency to rubles
when its army took control the ukrainian
grivener is being phased out
telephone networks are now russian the
russian soldier hands over his z
military badge as a form of id to a girl
selling russian phone sim cards another
soldier looks suspiciously at the camera
these people gather around a private
home to use its wifi connection because
internet coverage is hard to find
in the villages around here life for
some is even harder
only one shop is open
they bring food once or twice a week
mainly bread and grain but you need cash
and we don't have any because the atm
doesn't work there is no internet we
can't get in touch with our relatives we
live as if on an uninhabited island
people wait outside the only ukrainian
banks still operating it doesn't open
every day and russian banks are yet to
arrive
the russian army is never far away
large anti-russian demonstrations rarely
happen anymore russian forces have used
tear gas to break them up in the past
but there is still defiance
an increasingly dangerous and symbolic
gesture against russian occupation is
attaching yellow ribbons to things
ukrainians
underground movement continues our fight
says the man his face and voice heavily
disguised
every day we distribute leaflets and
yellow ribbons we share information with
the armed forces of ukraine about the
russian forces locations
friends we don't know if this video will
make it to you he says but know that the
claire's on underground movement is
working and continues to fight
this is a destroyed car belonging to a
ukrainian who was killed when it
exploded in a suspected bomb attack
after he accepted a job in the russian
administration
no one has claimed responsibility
there'd been at least three other
attempted murders of ukrainians
suspected of working with russian
occupying forces ukrainian military
intelligence says it's working to
recruit agents and partisans to work
inside russian occupied regions this
website in ukrainian and english was set
up by the ministry of defense and
ukrainian special forces it gives news
of partisan activity and guidance on how
people under occupation can resist
russian rule
it's difficult to know how many people
support russia's invasion in the
southern kirsan region
russia says it's planning to hold a
referendum in the autumn something
ukraine its western backers and many
people living under russian forces
say will be a farce
charles stratford al jazeera kiev